it certainly isn't easy to defeat the
Hulk but if you read the comics you
already know that it's not impossible
from adamantium claws super strength
beatdowns and even simple bullets the
Hulk's been taken down more times and
you might think although he definitely
always comes back here's every time the
Hulk has lost his life at the hands of
his enemies
friendly fire the Hulk's first demise
came at the hands of an anonymous
soldier in a 1965 issue of tales to
astonish after destroying one of Bruce
banners inventions before it can fall
into the wrong hands
The Hulk attempts to escape from the
leaders evil lab but is fired on by a
soldier it seems he was in the middle of
transforming back into banner at the
time because when the smoke cleared
banner is lying on the ground apparently
dead fortunately for the Hulk Rick Jones
steals the body and brings it back to
banner secret desert lab hoping he can
revive him by transforming him into the
Hulk it works but it's now banner in
control of the Hulk's body thanks to the
bullet lodged in his skull that keeps
him from turning back into his puny
alter-ego rather than deal with a Hulk
that's super strong and super smart the
Hulk's arch-nemesis the leader dissolves
the bullet with the most vaguely named
comic book science device ever the gamma
ray laser type beam the disease Bruce
Banner has found plenty of cures for his
condition over the years but every time
he does he immediately finds a really
good reason why he shouldn't have
bothered such was the case for the
Hulk's second death in Incredible Hulk
number 225 having been miraculously
cured Banner was helpless to fight off
an assault on gamma base by the leader
while his allies tried to convince him
to reimburse his Hulk e're side Banner
had what he thought was a better idea he
strapped himself into a gamma control
harness that he used to control a Hulk
robot unfortunately for him the leader
defeated the robot in the energy
feedback fatally electrocuted banner
like Rick Jones before him doc Samson
reasoned the only thing to do was to
blast banners body with gamma rays and
hope it turned him back into the Hulk it
worked but he probably regretted it when
the Hulk punched him through a wall not
a great way to say thanks Hulk the
rematch wolverine made his first
appearance all the way back in hulk
number 181 with a fight that didn't
exactly go
his way 14 years later in Hulk number
340 Logan returned with a vengeance and
handed the Hulk one of his most
devastating defeats the two run into
each other in a snowstorm when the x-men
stopped to save the passengers of an
airline the Hulk accidentally took down
by hitting at mid leap when Hulk finds
Wolverine amidst the planes wreckage he
picks a fight by attacking his old rival
Wolverine initially refuses but when he
finally cuts loose he Spears Hulk
through the torso with his claws
Wolverine believes the Hulk is a goner
but is shocked a few moments later when
the grey Hulk rises from the ground
clutching his chest saying let's try
that again
countdown the leader seems to be
involved with a lot of these deaths he'd
almost think he has a problem with the
whole in a story called countdown The
Hulk experiences multiple massive heart
attacks for reasons he can't figure out
after slugging it out with the
abomination the sheathing and the
leaders various henchmen the Big Brain
villain finally tells the Hulk that he
knows what's happening the Hulk has been
poisoned by a villain called madman and
leader wants madman dead after slowly
weakening and shrinking over the course
of a four part story
Hulk finally succumbs to the poison at
the start of Incredible Hulk number 367
after he revives he learns that madman
is leaders brother and after defeating
the bad guys he gets the cure for the
poison narrowly avoiding an oversized
coffin once again future imperfect
future imperfect isn't just one of the
Hulk's many deaths it's a twofer
in this story the Hulk travels to the
future and learns that one super-powered
villain rules over what's left of
humanity and that villain is a version
of himself called the maestro he's just
as intelligent as the Bruce Banner of
the present more vicious than the Hulk
ever was and in spite of his advanced
stage even stronger thanks to the
increased radiation in the environment
Hulk and maestro throwdown
twice during future imperfect their
first battle begins in an underground
rebel base and spills out onto the
streets of dystopia before the maestro
ends it by breaking the Hulk's neck
that's future imperfect Hulk death
number one the second comes when the
Hulk uses the same time machine that
brought him to the future to send
maestro to the Past specifically to the
exact moment the gamma bomb blasts that
change Banner into the Hulk the first
time
a hero unborn the onslaught event was
catastrophic for many heroes of the
Marvel Universe but none more so than
the Hulk after sacrificing themselves to
defeat onslaught the Fantastic Four and
the Avengers were sent to an alternate
universe called heroes reborn where
their stories were rebooted and they all
lived new lives with their new amazing
cheekbones meanwhile everyone back in
the regular universe thought they were
dead for the Hulk though it wasn't that
simple he was the one who delivered the
blow that shattered on slots armored and
it released so much power that Bruce
Banner and the Hulk were physically
separated from one another
Bruce Banner along with the Avengers in
the Fantastic Four was reborn in the new
timeline but the Hulk stayed where he
was in the immediate aftermath the new
Savage Banner 'less Hulk went wild with
his insights appearing to literally rip
out of his skin eventually an irradiated
cocoon formed around him and the
following issue a new kind of Hulk
emerged from the cocoon one with the
power and savagery of the green Hulk but
the viciousness of the grey Hulk years
later in Avengers number 684 we learned
that the cocoon didn't just change the
Hulk it killed him destructible after a
nice long well-deserved vacation from
his own violent death Bruce Banner
bought the proverbial farm once again at
the end of indestructible Hulk number 20
the series ended with a mystery an
unknown assailant shoots banner in the
back of the head on the final page
leading to the story being relaunched
with a new Hulk number one after surgery
a really long fight with the abomination
in just a tiny spoonful of Iron Man's
extremis formula the Marvel Universe is
introduced to doc green a version of the
Hulk which shares Bruce banners
intelligence but has a completely
different personality after launching a
crusade to remove the powers of
virtually every gamma-powered monster in
the Marvel Universe we finally learn who
was responsible for his attempted murder
dr. Melinda Luke and stern shot banner
but it was Betty Ross his longtime love
gave her the intelligence she needed to
pull it off after her own adventures as
the red she-hulk Ross was convinced her
former husband was going to cause an
extinction-level event in the near
future
heads up here's a Hulk death that
shouldn't count
but apparently does in Avengers Ultron
forever number one the Hulk is part of a
team of Avengers pulled from different
moments in
as soon as he enters the fray though
he's apparently decapitated by one of
Ultron's lackeys then in the issue that
follows we learned that the Hulk didn't
really lose his head he lost a mask
see the Hulk of Ultron forever is a very
early version of the Hulk pulled from
1963 s Incredible Hulk number six in
that strange issue banner transformed
into a form that had a big green Hulk
body and a little Bruce Banner head the
Hulk was forced to Don a Hulk mask to
hide his identity that's the Hulk who
shows up in Ultron forever and while
that shouldn't technically count as one
of his many deaths a flashback in
Avengers number 684 puts it in there
with the others
it seems the Hulk actually was
decapitated and just grew a tiny new
head the next issue the fallen before
civil war - number three most of the
heroes of the Marvel Universe thought
Bruce Banner was rid of the Hulk for
good Amadeus Cho had absorbed the gamma
radiation from banner and became the
totally awesome Hulk leaving banner
completely cured but then the inhuman
called Ulysses had a precognitive vision
of the original hulk on a rampage
apparently murdering most of Marvel's
heroes when those heroes confronted
banner they found he was researching
gamma radiation again and they were less
than happy before anything could be
resolved - arrows kill banner instantly
a flashback within a flashback revealed
that months ago banner had approached
Hawkeye with two arrows asking Hawkeye
to use them on him if he should ever
show signs of turning into the Hulk in
the aftermath Hawkeye claimed he saw
banners eyes flash with green but the
truth is left ambiguous whether or not
banner was about to turn into the Hulk
it's clear that Hawkeye could never have
done the deed at least not with as much
finality as banner wanted Bruce Banner
and the immortal Hulk are in the Marvel
Universe for good or for at least as
long as it takes them to pick another
adjective
[Music]